what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
an Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania is
officially out if you saw the movie
already and I'm assuming most of you
have since you are here please let us
know what you thought about the movie in
the comments down below did you like it
did you not like it did you expect more
let us know your thoughts now as per
usual with most Marvel movies we get two
extra scenes after the credits we have a
mid-credits scene and a post-credits
scene both of which are extremely
important one is very important for Loki
season two and also the MCU in general
and one is just insanely huge for the
MCU in general but also Kang Dynasty and
Avenger Secret Wars the next two
Avengers films that are coming out so
we'll start with the very first post
credit scene the first scene opens up
with a giant Coliseum we see many people
in the Coliseum but they are too far
away to make out then we see a giant
statue of King the Conqueror and as we
are seeing all of this we hear a voice
and the voice says so the exiled one we
then hear another voice and see a
variant of Kang come on screen with a
smile on his face saying you sure he's
dead we then see another Kang and we
hear him say if it weren't true I
wouldn't have called you then the other
one replies it must really eat you up
knowing that you weren't the one to kill
him and right as he says that we see
another king into the room and he says
none of us have killed him they did
they're beginning to touch the
Multiverse and if we let them they will
take everything we have so let's stop
wasting time he then says we are late
another variant asks how many did you
call and the main one says all of us it
then pans back to the Coliseum where we
see many many different variants of King
thousands of them entering the stadium
and sitting down in the stands the ones
that we see enter are entering the same
way that Reed Richards entered The
Illuminati's headquarters in Multiverse
of Madness and there's a reason for this
that we'll talk about in just a second
but in the audience we see thousands of
different versions of Kang we even see
Ace scroll version of Kang but the most
important thing is that everybody in the
audience is cheering for the three kings
entering the Coliseum now what we are
seeing here is called the Council of
kings in the comics the Council of Kang
was exactly what it says it is a council
of Kings different variants of Kang
usually the most powerful ones from
whatever Universe they come from and
they basically dictate whether or not
another variant of Kang is worthy enough
to have the name Kang so needless to say
these three kings are in charge now who
exactly are these three kings well they
are three really famous variants of King
the Conqueror the first one who looks
like he is from Egypt is because he is
actually from Egypt this is the variant
Rama Tut King the conqueror's name is
actually Nathaniel Richards and he is
from the 30th century and when he first
traveled back in time he traveled back
to ancient Egypt where he became the
ruler calling himself Rama Tut this is
that variant now what's really
interesting is that in the Comics he is
actually defeated by The Fantastic Four
and Nathaniel Richards is supposed to be
a descendant of Reed Richards Mr
Fantastic so this is the connection that
we have here with those teleporting
devices A Fantastic Four film is coming
to the MCU in a couple of years we've
already seen Reed Richards technology
and Multiverse of madness he is the
smartest man alive and his teleporting
device looks exactly like the ones that
Kang or Olive kangs are using in this
post-credits scene so Nathaniel Richards
AKA Kang could get his technology from
his ancestor Reed Richards and that
could be the major connection we have
there but there is also another really
cool connection like I said Rama Tut in
the comics gets defeated by The
Fantastic Four and he tries to go
forward in time but he ends up missing
his exit so to speak he overshoots it
and he ends up in a timeline where he
meets Dr Doom and the two of them
believe that they are actually related
to each other and this is hinted at in
the comics as well so basically the two
of them work together and Rama Tut AKA
Kang ends up making a suit made based
off of Dr Doom's suit and he calls
himself after this the Scarlet Centurion
and that is this other king that we see
on the right side now he doesn't exactly
look like his comic counterpart but
based off of the information that we
know this is the Scarlet Centurion then
we have what seems to be the main Kang
and this is immortus now this is where
things get kind of interesting because
in the comics of mortis isn't
necessarily a bad guy all of the time
he's more of an anti-hero and in fact
he's fought alongside the Avengers at
one point in time and often time he
tries to make sure that the other
variants of himself aren't controlling
the entire Multiverse and in the comics
he actually ends up in limbo which is
essentially the quantum realm a place
that time and space doesn't affect
giving him the power to live forever or
become immortal which is where he deemed
himself immortus but in limbo he
actually studies under the timekeepers
and they teach him about time so
although in Loki season 1 and in the MCU
the timekeepers might not be real in
Another Universe they actually might be
but what's really interesting is that at
one point in time immortus calls all of
the Kings together but this is actually
a trick and he plans to eliminate all of
them so he can be the only remaining
Kang and perhaps that could be what
amortis is up to here however
considering how all of the different
variants of Kang looked extremely happy
and were cheering for the Kang Trio I'm
assuming he doesn't plan to do that and
he actually plans to use these different
variants of King now the Council of
Kings obviously viewed The Avengers now
as threats and this actually happens in
the comics and animated series as well
the Council of kings are not supposed to
interfere with other Kang's timelines
but they do make exceptions when the
Avengers get too strong and it seems
like that is exactly what is going on
here so essentially this is the start of
the Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret
Wars the battle between not only the
Avengers but other Heroes as well that
exist in other universes and King all of
his variants of King not just in our
universe but across the Multiverse now I
might add that we're not exactly sure
that Kang died at the end of Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania he could still very
well be alive and still just be in a
different part of the quantum realm
after all he died in a very similar way
that Darren cross died at the end of the
first Ant-Man film and he ended up being
alive just inside of the quantum realm
so the Kang from Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania could still very well be
alive and he could actually be what's
called Prime King Prime King in the
comics is a variant of Kang Who Rose up
to power and started eliminating other
timelines of which other kings came from
and an Ant-Man and the WASP of
quantumania we actually did hear this
version of Kang talk about pruning the
others out of time who exiled him and
thanks to some flashbacks we've already
seen him conquering other timelines
eliminating them so this very well could
be prime Kang and he still very well
could be alive and Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios did confirm
that secret Wars is not only going to be
about our heroes versus Kings but Kang
versus Kings as well so that does it for
the first post credit scene let's move
on to the last one now the second
post-credits scene is actually setting
up Loki season 2. not much has really
been released about Loki season 2 as far
as the plot is concerned however at the
end of Loki season 1 after Sylvie killed
he who remains Loki found himself back
at the TVA however there were no statues
of the timekeepers there were simply
statues of Kang he ran over to Mobius to
tell him about everything but Mobius did
not know who he was but Loki told him
that they needed to prepare for Kang to
come and that he is absolutely
terrifying so in the second post-credits
scene we find ourselves looking at
another variant of Kang this is most
likely in the 1910s or the 1920s because
this variant that we see on stage is the
variant of Kang called Victor timely and
in the audience we see Loki and Mobius
Loki is absolutely terrified but Owen
Wilson's Mobius makes a joke that this
guy really doesn't look that bad kind of
implying are you really afraid of this
guy now Victor timely is a variant of
Kang who ends up losing badly in the
future so he goes back in time in the
early 1900s to basically start over he
uses his technology and knowledge about
the future to establish a town and
become mayor of it he also starts many
different businesses and becomes very
wealthy now what's interesting about
Victor timely is that like I mentioned
before Prime Kang Victor timely is
actually Prime King so he ages at a lot
slower rate so he's around for a very
long time so much like King go from the
eternals has had to say that he was a
descendant of his
great-great-grandfather and so on and so
forth Victor timely has to do the same
eventually Victor timely dies on paper
of course not really he does this to not
attract suspicion but then he just calls
himself Victor timely Jr so King Never
Dies but he is smart to know that people
get suspicious so he just simply says
that he dies but he's the son or the
grandson or the great grandson of Victor
timely and we could be looking at Prem
Kang in this post credit scene a king
who wants to get rid of all of the other
kings and if you think about it this is
exactly what he who remains did in Loki
he was involved in the multiversal war
but then he harnessed the power of
eliaith and he won he then managed to
isolate his timeline having no timelines
Branch out therefore having no Kinks
created and essentially won the war so
we could be looking at an early version
here of he who remains Victor timely
could eventually turn into he who
remains that we saw from Loki perhaps
this is why Loki and Mobius are visiting
him here they could be trying to stop
Kang from turning into he who remains
and that could be what Loki season 2 is
about so that's it for the two post
credit scenes for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania of course be sure to let us
know your thoughts on Ant-Man
quantumania and the two post credit
scenes in the comments down below please
don't forget to give the video a like
And subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos and for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf
thank you